you're like the whole milk version of an
Elon Musk you know what I mean you're
the Midwest version of an Elon Musk but
what the hell did you know about
building a [__] airplane you know
what I mean what did you did you know
anything about that no I did not I
um
knew nothing I was just like I really
wanted to do it
[Music]
all right everyone we have a really
interesting guest his name is Brett
Adcock I've talked about him on the Pod
a bunch of times but let me explain why
this guy's interesting so he started a
recruiting website that he sold for a
hundred million dollars which in most
everyone's case that's a massive home
run you're incredibly successful of what
she is but then he parlayed that and
invested pretty much 100 of his money
into another company called Archer which
basically makes like unmanned
helicopters and then that took went
public at like a 1.5 billion valuation
and he started another company called
figure which is making humanoids they're
basically robots that can work
warehouses and do uh human labor the
reason I wanted Brett to come on is
because I just wanted to think and learn
about how someone who's so unique how
they think and how they make decisions
and so Brett's really subtle he's a he's
a Loki guy he's not crazy high energy
um he's not one of these guys who we
have on who is a a personality where
they have a big personality on on
YouTube or Twitter or anything like that
he's subtle man the guy's humble and
he's quiet and I find that to be
incredibly fascinating my opinion in 10
years
Brett is going to be in the running of
however we think of like these like
Howard Hughes Elon Musk types of crazy
folks who build these amazing
world-changing things Brett's gonna be
that I mean he's already up there but I
think he's going to be like that and no
one knows who he is now or at least uh
compared to some of those other folks so
what I want you to do is listen to this
episode particularly like the last 15
minutes when we talk about his latest
company
it's really fascinating and I want you
to tweet at me my handle's the sampar
p-a-r-r so the the word the and then Sam
and then par tweet at me and let me know
what you think about this guy and what
makes people like him special because
I'm really fascinated with these types
of personalities and I'm fascinating
with how people can learn so much
information so quickly it's just really
fascinating to me so let me know give it
a listen his name's Brett Adcock let's
start the show all right dude let's just
get right into it the reason you're
interesting to me is because you're
incredibly successful I imagine you're
worth hundreds of millions of dollars
but you
you go all in on stuff so you told me
with this new company figure you
financed it for the first year and you
put up most all of your money into it I
was like I was like what what what's
your asset allocation for your personal
portfolio and you're like well I own
Archer stock which I took public I own a
house and then I put some huge amount of
money which if you want you could say
into the my company figure and I'm going
all in on them and I and I just go hard
I go all in is that right yeah
this has really been out of necessity
um my career when I started battery I
couldn't get anybody to invest
in the business for the first like
almost like three years uh so I
basically put all my savings into the
company took no salary for three or four
years how much savings did you have
you're 25. I think I had like close to
200 000 I put into the business
um and then you know I didn't take any
salary for three years I meant like
um had to pay for my own health care or
food rent I was living in Manhattan it's
really expensive and 2015 things got so
bad that I had to borrow
I think it was fifty thousand dollars to
pay for rent and survive
I had like credit card debt I was yeah I
was probably in the red like negative a
hundred thousand dollars
prior to the acquisition of energy well
what did battery exit for
um 110 million so that was a that was a
windfall right yeah that was great I
raised like a little over 10 million
dollars over like seven years
so I had a large you know percentage
ownership of the company so but yeah
overnight success from going from
you know seven years of Agony and debt
to like having capital for the first
time in a significant way and then did
you I don't know if you're telling me
these stories like when you're if you're
goofing around or not but you said that
you put most all of your money into
Archer right
yeah
um
when I so I started archer in 2018 so I
called Arch radiation and uh we build um
electric vertical takeoff and Landing
aircraft so these are basically aircraft
somewhat similar to a helicopter but
they're purely electric and they're
they're the goal is to use the aircraft
to move people around cities so the
traffic's just like such a terrible
phenomenon nobody's really worked on
traffic for 100 years so we were
basically out there I was out there
trying to solve the traffic problem and
kind of help help the sustainability and
the pitch coming out of battery was just
it was bad like it was um hey we need um
basically probably about a billion
dollars maybe more to get the market or
we or we don't make it we're designing
this new type of transportation system
in the air so instead of driving to the
airport you would fly and it needs to be
fully electric that nobody in history
had ever certified an electric aircraft
before and I was coming off a software
you know 10 years 15 years in software
so that that pitch did not really
resonate too well
in 2018. you're like uh we made a joke
in the last pod where I'm like if you
drink a glass of milk with dinner you're
my type of guy like people were making
fun of me from being from Midwest you're
like you're like the whole milk version
of an Elon Musk you know what I mean
you're the Midwest version of the of a
neon musk but what the hell did you know
about
I mean software is easy in a sense like
you know like it's just code right like
No One's Gonna Die if you if you screw
it up or in most cases No One's Gonna
Die and if I talk to a guy who's doing
like Computer Engineering or computer
science I'm like what the hell do you
know about building a [__] airplane
you know what I mean what did you did
you know anything about that no I did
not I
um
I knew nothing I was just like I really
wanted to do it that doesn't make sense
to me
yeah what do you do that doesn't make
sense to me like if I wanted to go learn
about how an airplane is built I guess I
would like or or a unmanned drone I
don't know what you want to call it I
would go I guess I would well first of
all you have to have a high IQ to begin
with which I don't but I would like what
I what would I do I guess I would call
people who know what they're talking
about and ask them what books do you
read and then I would go and read the
books and take lessons and maybe I'll go
to like a college a few college courses
I don't know like it just seems like an
impossible thing to learn and you
learned it in how many years so yeah so
here's what I did I um
one is I spent a tremendous amount of
time after a veteri figuring out what I
wanted to work on next I kind of fell
into the recruiting Marketplace space
with veteri and I really wanted to be
very thoughtful
um about what I wanted to work on so I
basically spent a large amount of time
figuring out okay what is the right
opportunity I want to spend my time on
and it was Archer it was very clear to
me I wanted to do Archer Aviation and
build it so the first thing I did is I
basically built a spreadsheet and I
called everybody in the I could I could
think of in the world uh so I think I
made um I think that spreadsheet is
about 300 people I connected with
whether they're at NASA or professors or
working in Industry at rotorcraft or
airplanes or turbofan development
whatever it would look like and I just
immerse myself and I want to know every
technical book that was on on the market
I wanted to understand how to build
electric aircraft like what are the
components and what are the physics
governed by in the space and uh I
probably spent almost six months in a
room just making phone calls like cold
calling everybody in the world what's
that call look like hey uh Mr Conway my
name's Brett yeah um yeah can you talk
to me about helicopters it's it's crazy
man like people people will pick up the
phone for you like it's just like you
just gotta pick up the phone and call
and people will talk to you people wanna
people wanna help what was the most uh
like breathtaking call you had or
meaningful call you had I did a I did a
meeting so I I in addition to calling
everybody in the world
the parallel track was I was going back
to school so I went back and like
learned how to do uh like mechanical and
aerospace engineering and you know
leading up to that I went to an event in
2018. I think it was 2018 it's like
early 2018 at this point it was at this
Hyatt like like basically Hyatt Hotel in
Atlanta was hosting this like electric
um aircraft design course so it was a
lot of aerodynamics folks and uh folks
in the industry that really wanted to
understand the physics around electric
aircraft I went down there and I
basically sat for two days uh being
lectured on how to build an aircraft
electric aircraft from scratch how to
think about the propulsion aerodynamics
uh batteries and
um it was it was just like all my heroes
today electric Aviation and one of the
guys there was in his PhD at the
University of Florida and said
me too I'm doing my PhD electric
Aviation and I want to build an EV tile
aircraft and I go to the University of
Florida and I said wow I went to I went
to undergrad at University of Florida as
well he's like you need to come by ASAP
and see our lab where I'm trying to
build electric aircraft and you know
smaller scale and we could help you so I
did this course I got on a plane I went
down to Gainesville and I met the the
head of the group there and
um he's basically the the head of all
mechanical aerospace engineering
University of Florida and he had this
like basically 12-person lab building
things like hobby grade like electric
aircraft drones
and I said I want to take this lab over
and I want to just build
um electric aircraft
um and uh this lab happened to be off of
Archer Road
so I called the business Archer Aviation
what percentage of the veteri windfall
did you put into this education portion
as well as our starting Archer I like
all of it yeah all of it but what does
that actually mean like how are you
living
well I was living off the cache so I I
had just from from veteri just like paid
my bills I took no salary at Archer for
two years I don't know something like
that like this is a zero
um like cover Insurance type thing and
um
you know I made like I went from like
having nothing to like having tens of
millions of dollars after tax so it was
you know it was a lot of money I just
didn't need I didn't need almost any of
it so I wanted to work on
this new new thing and no nobody would
like I couldn't even get meetings
at one point I got introduced like a the
guy that runs like General Catalyst Joel
and um
he called my pitch disrespectful what do
you say
he was like it was like mid it was like
right when covet hit and uh I got a big
introduction from him uh from like one
of my investors Mark Laurie introduced
me to Joel he's like this is the best
guy you got you got to talk to him and I
got to call Joel and he's just like I
gotta stop you right here man
this is the most disrespectful pitch
I've ever seen we have people dying
because of covid I think the hospitals
are filled up and you're asking me for
money
like for like for this like flying car
idea like what are you talking about
it's just not possible like why would
you be doing this
and I said like I'm running out of money
personally like I need somebody to fund
us or we're also like you know I know I
know covet's bad but the business is
gonna die and this is what you do you
fund companies like this is why I'm
calling you like this is um
and yeah I would say probably gonna stay
the worst phone call I've ever taken so
I sold my company three years ago and I
had the same thing where I like I didn't
I was I was just barely getting by and
then overnight things changed and I was
like I'm gonna spend six or twelve
months just like seeking planning I'm
gonna figure out what because I don't I
don't know if you took time off but I
took like three months of like kind of
normal 20 or 40 hour work weeks and low
stress and I was like all right cool
that's what I needed I felt recharged I
need to get back to it
except when I went back to it I was like
have you heard of icky guy it's like
this like for it's like this Japanese
like uh concept where there's like four
rings that overlap and one of the Rings
is like uh what does the world want to
pay for the other ring is what does the
world want the other one is what do I
enjoy doing and then what am I great at
and like ideally you find something
right in the middle because if you find
something that you're great at that you
have skills at but the world doesn't
want to pay for it that's just like an
expensive hobby if you find something
the world wants and they're willing to
pay for and you're good at but you hate
it that's just like a crappy job so like
you want to find something right in the
middle so I was like what am I skilled
at and basically I I thought of it like
I'm just gonna use my skills and what do
I enjoy and I'm just gonna try and do
something slightly better and I think
that's a pretty rational way to go about
doing things like most people are uh
they're like I don't want to do too hard
too outside of my realm what interests
me about you is like you're kind of an
alien like you like we're like all right
this software thing this veteran thing
it worked I don't know if it worked as
good or as as you wanted it to or not I
don't know the full story but you just
like took a total 180 and you're like
screw the 15 years of Internet
experience that I'm doing I'm going to
do Aviation Hardware I'm going to do a
totally different thing
what do you think is is unique about you
that makes it so you don't actually want
to like go the easy route because I know
at veteri I think you like built did you
build like the email marketing software
like that's pretty like
it's a very narrow Niche and you did
something not even within it within that
Niche not even related to it and you
took the totally different route what do
you think is inside of you that makes
you do that because I find that
fascinating
I think at the end of the day I just
wanna
want to wake up it's like a amazing
future that's exciting inspiring are you
motivated by money not really no
um I think if I
wanted to make a lot of money I'm
probably in the wrong field you know I
think like the like there's like a risk
reward balance in startups like I think
if if it was just about money I think
I'd be basically probably back in
software still uh I think going and
doing these projects I'm working on now
or just probably the
probably the surest path to losing
everything
when you're starting figure
um like you know you read about Elon
Musk and he's like well I put everything
in and he's like I was sleeping on
couches and it's like well the couch was
like Sergey Brin you know it was like
his couch which probably isn't like a
normal couch you know it's probably the
couch in the living room of the guest
house and you just don't want to go use
the king-sized bed but like when you're
starting figure
are you ever worried about running out
of money and losing everything that
you've earned
I basically almost went
um personally bankrupt last year the
figure what yeah tell me that yeah so
when I left Archer I had basically you
know all my asset all my money tied up
into Archer like just had like and you
you can't sell that as an officer right
yeah so like Insider yeah we were like
you know I I made it pretty uh clear
when I started the business and even
when I went public that like uh me as
the like as a founder and CEO I'm not
selling stock we're pre-revenue I told
the board this I told all of our
investors this I even put a million
dollars in the in the spec
uh pipe as we went public at 10 bucks
and so
um personally I was like I'll put
another million dollars in here a three
billion dollar evaluation to show you
guys
that's all I got and um
and when I left I left archer in April
of 2022 I had 12-month stock lockup this
is public like there's an SEC document
for this
and so I couldn't I couldn't I couldn't
sell
a majority of all my stock was fully
locked up until April of this year
so I had some percentage I could sell
over over some time series I could sell
a certain amount of stock limited by
certain volumes of the market cap so
there wasn't just that much volumes a
year ago so I was selling some stock to
function figure and the stock went from
like when I left the stock was at five
or six bucks it wouldn't take a dollar
eighty
end of last year earlier this year and I
I was just like I don't know if I can
get to I don't know if I can get the 12
month Mark which was uh 12 month Mark
was April of 2023. that's like April you
know April 18th 2023 Promised Land like
I can sell unlimited stock no volume
restriction all stock lockup which which
I'm you know I have a bunch of stocks
though here I'm not selling right now
but like um but that was the point where
I needed to get to and
I thought you know I was underwriting
and seeing that stocks at three four
five six seven dollars like no problem
I'll be able to get there and we were
building a team teams that like was that
you know 40 or something like that we're
building we're spending like millions of
Hardware bigger yeah we were like we
were within six months we were at seven
figure a month burn
I figure
and I was just like it was like Shell
stock transferred to bank account uh
transfer it into the company pay payroll
it was like how fast can we get that
done
and it was like a full system of like
trying to get the like not hitting the
limits every day on stock selling uh
getting the cash into the bank account
and putting money in the figure
and um
and I wasn't you know this was like
there was a recession we were in the
banks were going bankrupt it wasn't like
it was a pretty market for series a or
categorizing it was the worst Market
since we've been in since the financial
crisis uh from a from a fundraising
perspective I had a stock of stocks
going down like 75 percent
and I was just like I'm running out of
cash
so I'm in my same I'm in my Hampton
group
and I'm like everybody's like what's
your you know most most important thing
you're doing right now it's you know
talk about I'm like I'm running out of
money I might not make it what did they
say what was their feedback I I think
they were I thought I think they thought
I was a maniac I think everyone thinks
you're a maniac yeah I mean like I've
talked to a lot of people who know you
that's what fascinates me about you but
what fascinates me about you is that
your hand you handle stress differently
like I I've toured your factory and you
were like smiling and like jumping
around like you uh like it seems like
you're like Jolly almost I don't know
you're showing me this [__] I remember
going to your factory or your office and
you're like check this out we got the
knee working and like you see like a
knee or ankle I don't know what it was
like you see some something of the robot
and you and there was like 18 or 10
people just sitting around and it felt
like I was hanging out with like buddies
in a garage like just watching you guys
finally figure out how to work like a
remote control car or something like
ridiculous and it seemed exciting though
like I remember being there and I met
like I have to be part of this and it
was exciting but I didn't I I know that
you go all in on things I didn't realize
how close you were to running out of
money
like I don't understand how you deal
with that like what's your wife saying
when you're like hey we might file for
bankruptcy personally in the next couple
months yeah I think it's even worse like
we I had a second mortgage on my house
to get through it no way what did she
say yeah so I also in the category of
like you know people thinking I'm a
maniac my wife's just she's been with me
for 15 years now
through all of this like we lived in you
know thousand dollar a month apartment
in New York we had to downsize two to
get through the veteri stuff
um
to you know to to now Archer and figure
she's great like she's she's a warrior
she like Believes In Me and she
has total faith in what we're doing and
I don't take these things lightly like a
really these are like planned exercises
I need to go through
um
and I've been been through many
near-death experiences I mean Archer
like like what I went through a figure
was probably like a tip of the iceberg
to what I went through at Archer last
like like five years like Archer was
just uh you know a go in public was just
like a recipe to get sued and we were
going public to us the SPAC process we
you know as soon as we price the SPAC
deal the market turned on spacks it was
it was just a roller coaster
um so yeah I just I've been through many
exercises like this before and I think I
can weather them pretty well now
I don't know anything about like
business finances I remember when we
started our company I didn't know the
difference between cash flow and revenue
which was like a pretty big deal you
need to know that I didn't know what
that was until like
three years into the company and I was
like I thought cash flow and revenue
were the same thing I don't understand
how to read a balance sheet I don't know
how to do any of that so I'm I'm um
taking classes right now to like figure
that out and I was Googling stuff and I
found this website it's called
streetofwalls.com
so I went to Street of walls and there's
these amazing articles where you click
start training and there's like it looks
like a book so if you're on your
computer go to streetofwalls.com so
there's like introduction there's like
what does an investment Bank do there's
like how do you do a discounted cash
flow analysis there's all this stuff and
I scroll to the bottom
and I always click the about page uh and
there's a link that says file this site
and author on Twitter
and I clicked the Twitter
and it was you you wrote you made this
website and I was like texting this is
pretty funny I was texting you ahead of
time I go hey I know you took a company
public I don't know anything about
finances how did you learn how to do it
and you're like oh I actually taught
myself how to do it and then I did most
of the preparation work for the IPO and
I was like that's amazing and you didn't
even tell me you had this site where it
was like a whole site of your learning
and education what was the site what is
streetofwalls.com yeah so I so when I
when I went to college
I enrolled in uh like industrial and
system Engineering also Finance this is
like you know not something I also talk
about a lot but like I basically did a
few years in finance after school before
like doing the startup life why don't
you talk about that was that
embarrassing it just doesn't the pitch
doesn't isn't great like I think like
people just don't like hearing about
Finance folks and I also didn't really
enjoy it like I think
you know I look at those years of saying
man I wish I was like spending more time
doing technology development and I was
working full-time but building startups
and stuff on the side
and
um
I just look at that saying like I think
it was helpful in some ways but like
probably net net like would have been
more important just for me to dive in
and start building businesses full time
um so I was at you know in school
somebody gave me this book
it's called like the fast track to like
invest in banking management consulting
and trading and I read it and it was
like you know people are going to
finance like Drive Ferraris they just
like do so well and they make 150 000
after school and I was like I was dead
broke in college like taking out loans
to the paper school and I was like man
I'm gonna just go this is how I'm gonna
you know make some money
start my career and I went into like
interview with Goldman Sachs and I just
I just whiffed like they asked me like
um some accretion dilution you know uh
like M A modeling and lbo questions or
leverage buyout questions and I just I
didn't know anything
and they're like you know I think the
guy was nice he was like listen you just
you have to have a certain like bar of
understanding of financial finances he's
like this is such a disrespectful
interview yeah this is the second time
you're disrespecting people constantly
yeah exactly and um it's like you're
like wasting my time and I was like man
like
um I'm not really learning how to do
this stuff in college so I'm just gonna
have to go alert it and
um you know I was learning that I just
started like writing notes and writing
about it and
um when my brother actually went to
finance my brother works at a private
Equity company now I was like I'm just
gonna repackage all these notes I'm
gonna put them online and also give them
my brother and um like like when I'm
where am I going to use them again and
that was the Genesis for a street of
walls we've I think I've gotten like 30
million views
uh of that site the last like you know
15 years which has been
which has been great like a lot of folks
have been like this has been my primary
reason I've gotten a job and
um but you know as you can see I've I
haven't spent a nickel on it and over a
decade
do you how do they get traffic I mean
according to similar web it's still
getting a hundred thousand or so people
a month coming to it it's all organic
SEO that's insane I mean that's kind of
a lot right I mean for such a high uh
for this would be an expensive term to
rank for yeah these are like you know
there's thousands of pages of content
there with good original content and
it's you know it's just ranking high on
Google you wrote all these I wrote all
those articles yeah were you going to
turn this into a business
yeah I saw at one point I was making
like five thousand dollars a month
selling those interview guides
like like one year out of college
it was great I mean it was like a 98
margin business okay well when you're in
that position what's stopping you from
going full time on that because if I'm
broke and I'm 24 and I'm making five
grand a month I'm like this is the thing
yeah I I didn't I I strongly believe
like I I strongly believe I need to
touch like the mass market and um
to have like significant impact in
technology you need to have like a
a either a lot of people using your
product or very few that use it like
really like it a lot and I just felt
like the products the services I was
starting were just
um not important enough
for my time so in the Pod we on this pod
we talk a lot about like ideas and like
different opportunities in terms of
Veterinary what opportunities did you
see that you guys weren't able to pounce
on that still exists
one of the things we did is um
you know so work so I started the
battery at the NYU incubator
um and
um one of the guys there
handed me a book one day and it's like
it was it was the predictable Revenue
book uh which is basically like an
outbound lead generation marketing
Playbook
he said hey you need to read this so
it'd probably be pretty helpful for
veteri
um and uh those guys it was actually tap
Commerce those guys sold for like over
100 million to Twitter uh so it was
Brian Dondo there and um I ended up
reading the book it's like this is great
we need to like replicate the system
fully end to end
so I started like working on
um writing this uh outbound lead
generation uh process and we ultimately
gave it to
um basically a person that's here with
me today so Lee randazzio gave it to her
and said hey can you you go go figure
out how to build this
so she brought on an engineer and we
basically built this outbound lead
generation Software System that
basically ended up powering all a
battery
so that was basically like how do we put
uh contact information of people and
basically do this Cadence of emails out
to folks to do like basically drum up
leads and you can do this for both like
customers where did you get the emails
uh we had we built an offshore team of
like 300 people in the Philippines
and we did it all by scratch what does
that mean going to LinkedIn or something
and just build yeah you can
um basically finding the right people
based on job titles and then there's a
process where you can use to find emails
pretty well like there's you know uh
there's a lot on GitHub there's a lot of
you can get the emails through Facebook
pretty easily there's a basically a
process where you can basically back
into somebody's personal email address
there's also like databases
you can use a lot of folks shoes so we
would get emails plug them into this
machine and go
and we basically built this like huge
engine that would power like millions of
emails we were doing per month
and then um I think it was like an early
2013 2014 there was like the startup
emerging
um which is Outreach
and we demoed it we're like this is the
same exact thing we just built
internally you know Outreach now is like
a four or five billion dollar company
and we're like watching Outreach scale
up we have a product that this is
literally built internally ourselves
that we're just using ourselves at the
time we thought it was a little bit
better so we didn't use outrage that was
more customized for what we're doing
everything else but uh it was really
funny to see us you know me go out and
build like a 100 million dollar company
when internally we had a four billion
dollar company sitting internally uh so
there was there was a few of those that
happened through the life of battery
that were it was just interesting to see
and
um I think that goes back to my same
theme which is like be very thoughtful
like so so my my time now is haunted by
am I working on the right things do you
think that was the wrong thing I I think
battery was the right thing for me at
the right time but it was definitely not
the right thing to do it was definitely
the right call to get into Archer next
in the figure
and
um I use it as a learning lesson to say
what happened with better is I fell into
it I fell into it from Street of walls I
fell into it because I built up this
huge database of traffic from like from
from content and then I use that to help
build and bootstrap the marketplace with
battery
it wasn't as if I like I was in college
when I kind of the stuff started and
said
um I want to go do recruiting this is
where I'm going to spend the rest of my
life in it just I just fell into it and
um happened to work out really well and
I think I wouldn't have been able to
start Archer if it wasn't for the
veterinary acquisition
so you know I think
I think looking back it was something I
would have done again but I used that
less I use that as a lesson to say
I do have a choice on what to spend my
time on and everybody does and it's the
most pressed asset you have because we
don't have that much time left
all right I gotta tell you about one
thing that's one of the great joys of my
life and I'm not a cars guy I'm not a
watch guy but there's one thing that
gives me a lot of joy and that is having
a virtual assistant uh you know here's
the scenario I'm running my companies
and even though I'm supposed to be this
uh CEO we all know I spend 20 30 of my
time just doing random [__] stuff
that is not high value but it's just
tedious the stuff that has to get done
but it's not creativity doesn't require
me and it doesn't add a bunch of value
to the business it's just stuff just
stuff that has to get done and so that
stuff is what a virtual assistant does
like just this week alone you know I
lose my wallet so she goes to the DMV
website fills out a bunch of forms it
gets me a new license or um you know
every morning people have their morning
coffee I have my morning metrics and my
morning metrics are basically all the
business metrics that I care about
compiled she goes she finds them for all
the different sources puts it in Excel
sheet takes a screenshot text it to me
so that when I wake up in the morning I
don't go on Twitter or check my email
I'm looking at what are what are the
metrics at and what do I need to do I'm
focused on the right things so having a
virtual assistant is a no-brainer
whether it's travel booking email inbox
or just knocking stuff off your personal
to-do list that would have just lingered
there forever
um I think it's a no-brainer if you're a
business owner you should definitely do
it
um I think one of the best ways to find
a assistant is Shepard so go to support
shepherd.com you know I pay my assistant
I think eight dollars an hour something
like that that's double what she was
making in her previous job so it's a win
for her and for me it's super affordable
it's something that you know you don't
need to have the biggest business ever
be the biggest big shot in order to
afford it so it's amazing I now do this
for my CEO and my cm02 like I just give
them assistance without them even asking
because I know it makes them more
productive that's it does that for me so
of course it's gonna do that for them
too so go to sportsshopper.com check
them out
um get an assistant and tell them I sent
you they'll take good care of you if you
do that so sportsrefer.com check it out
I can't find this client info have you
heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow better
what was the math that you saw or like
the graph or whatever that made you want
to start figure like what was there a
signal where you're like oh man this can
be the biggest company in the world
because I think you saw that to me you
go we will either go to screw up and go
bankrupt or we'll have a very small exit
or it's going to be a 100 billion dollar
company or you said something like that
where it was like this is either gonna
be the biggest thing ever or total
failure but what did you see that gave
you the idea that this could be the
biggest thing
so so what what we're doing to here
figure is we're building humanoid robots
these are robots when we see humanoid I
mean it it looks like the human form so
it has legs arms hands
we're not trying to look like a human
but we're trying to do everything a
human can do and when you look at the
world today if you like go out in the
world and look at everything you're
doing it requires a human interface in
the physical world
so the equivalent to I always make an
analogy is when you use the internet
using a keyboard and mouse and you can
interact all the internet you can use a
keyboard your little your fingers are
like your little little keyboard and
mice
um you can basically interact with all
the digital world the physical world
will last several hundred years we built
to interact with the human body so we
have like door handles we have tools we
have stairs everything around us was
built for a human interface and so
when you look at what we're doing here
is we're trying to build an automation
solution to do physical labor how do we
get into the world and do human-like
tasks and when you look at the market
for human
human-like tasks it's half from GDP
so like you know
GDP is roughly 70 80 trillion half of
that is goes to human labor to pay wages
every single year in the world and it's
roughly half or so for you know for if
you go to any company or any country in
the world it's roughly half a GDP
and what we've seen now is we've seen
this like we seem like these emergent
properties happen in in the kind of the
space we operate here that are allowing
us to build and do this this decade we
have Hardware from like um that is that
is capable of being built to do
human-like tasks
and then from a software perspective
separately we have software today and we
have ai systems today that can basically
understand like semantically what's
going on in the world and do human-like
uh applications from a software
perspective
so here at figure what's so so at a high
level
the biggest company the next 10 15 years
in the world will be humanoid like AI
powered humanoids
that like that's for sure going to
happen
the question is like what groups are
going to do that well I think Elon Musk
let me find this quote I have this quote
here I think he said um Tesla has a
robot I think it's called Optimus so
Elon says it'll probably cost less than
twenty thousand dollars to build and it
will be a bigger business than cars so
like it's going to be huge
um and so you you just looked at that
math and you're like I have to go all in
on this but what's the business model
like you you rent them out to people or
you sell them to people what do you do
yeah you can do either I mean this
there's a there's definitely a similar
capex model that is very similar to how
we like buy and buy cars today where you
would want to you know buy the asset it
would have a certain amount of
depreciable lives
um you'd have to like pay for services
and maintenance and then there's another
model which is like operating model
which is we're calling it robots of
service which is a leasing model so you
basically be able to put robots into say
you know uh warehousing or manufacturing
related applications and you would
charge basically a monthly fee for that
work and that would be a kind of a lower
price per year that you would pay but
ongoing and um so we you know here at
figure we're pushing the robotism
service operating model we think it's
the way to get costs down to make it
affordable to the masses
um and but some of the initial
conversations we're having with clients
too is that they're you know interested
in buying them because they've been
buying robots for you know a decade so I
think we're open to kind of getting out
of the world what um we're seeing here
is we're seeing the ability to get these
robots over time with the high enough
volumes cheaper than like a mid-priced
car
um and then if that robot can last
four or five years before it's fully
depreciated
um the cost should be pretty affordable
for the even even for the home we should
be able to put robots in the home for
you know several hundred dollars per
month
I was talking to my family members as
they're like are you talking to tomorrow
I was like man it's the guy Brett he
builds a humanoid it's like and they're
like what the hell you know what the
[__] is that I'm like well it's
like you know how like Amazon workers do
this stuff it's gonna do that and then
like inevitably the answer is like oh so
he's gonna put everyone out of work all
right that's cool what's your rebuttal
to that like how do you think about that
like you know you seem very like
altruistic and you're like you're like I
want to save the world so what do these
people what are they gonna do and when
are they going to lose their jobs so
what we're seeing from like a labor
perspective is that the the amount of
people in the workforce is starting to
shrink so we have like roughly 3.3
billion humans working in uh in the
world
a big chunk of that is the Baby Boomers
and they're retiring out of the market
and then from uh you know from the other
side we're basically having roughly a
little over one
um child per household at this point
we're well under the replacement rate
for humans which needs to be like like
about 2.2 uh bursts per household so
we're like we're not putting more into
the uh uh the top of the funnel we're
not putting any more in and the bottom
funnel we're retiring now so we're
basically shrinking the labor force so
when we walk into
um I think the conventionalism is what
you say it's like you walk into one of
these like big big companies and they're
like we're worried about you taking our
people's jobs like how are we going to
message this like what are they going to
do that is complete 180 from what we see
with boots in the ground if you if you
actually do the work of walking into a
company that's big and you ask them
their number one problem they'll say
employee headcount in in retention
so we walk into these warehouses
manufacturing retail whatever
and we walk in and they're telling us
that 15 of employees don't show up every
day to work
they're saying they have two to three
percent weekly attrition 50 to 150
annual turnover
the working conditions are harsh it's
really hot in the Summers it's cold in
the winters you have to walk miles per
day you have to pick like a lot of items
per hour
it's a lot easier to drive an Uber in
this condition than be in these
facilities
so when we walk into these clients they
they have a labor crisis going on
and they need help ASAP and they can't
figure out how to automate these more
dexterous and human-like tasks
and so um you know our goal is to go in
there and do like the dirty and hard
work that they can't find humans to do
today and we think there's just
problem I've never seen a business like
this where we walk in and they're like
we'll buy a million of them if you can
do this
and so the the demand is like I think it
almost unbounded I don't even know how
to
handicap it it's if you can build the
technology we need Millions when we were
hanging out I was like why don't you
just do a software company and you're
like software is harder and I was like
what why he goes well because I had to
make people like want Veterinary like I
had to convince them that this was a
good idea and then like I had infinite
options on what to build and I had to
hope that I was building the right thing
and then he said with Hardware I can
find problems where there's already
demand I know if I could if if I'm able
to build this people will want it and I
know that there's a set of laws dictated
by physics of which create the rules and
I just have to figure out within that
very small set of rules can I build this
and as of now you're like I think I can
but I haven't entirely figured it out
but it's a much simpler puzzle to figure
out in order to like build this thing
and if I build it the business is is
going to be the biggest thing ever
because I know people want that and I
remember like when you said that it kind
of it changed my perspective on on a lot
of things did I say that right yeah I
think that's
pretty accurate like in software you
have a lot of these things that are
these emergent properties that happen in
like say the marketplace or SAS
characteristics that make it really hard
to control you have retention and you
have competitive threats and you have
like feature build there's a lot of
things you need to do to kind of keep
the
the wheels in the car and keep it
running and in Hardware
um
if if there is demand for the product it
really puts the focus on the technology
development so at Archer
we already know people are driving to
the airport there's like in LA there are
60 million people driving around every
day and six million of them are taking
over an hour going like
10 15 miles
so like you know you go to like Pasadena
to LAX if you could fly that in seven
minutes or you want to drive that an
hour and a half like what do you want to
do for your time we know if you can fly
that in seven minutes and it's safe and
it's affordable over time a good amount
of folks will take that service
so it really puts the burden on the
technology development of like
can you go build something that is safe
and affordable and uh like you know and
gets good performance like in the
reliability side so that was the that's
the Archer case a similar figure it's
the case of can you get robots that can
actually do useful work
and this is governed by physics There
Are Rules there are equations so like
there is no like um I don't need to have
to go out and invent a new physics
equation or like aerodynamic equation to
make that happen I understand how an air
foil will will behave in a fluid I
understand how battery cells discharge
like we we understand all those rules
so it really puts the burden on us to
like think about like what's really
important here and what's really
important if I had like beam back the
most important thing to myself 20 years
ago I would say Brett
what really matters or what doesn't
matter is like marketing PR who you
raise capital from the tech crunch
article like none of that is Meaningful
it'll make you feel good as a Founder
because it's usually
extremely shitty for like so many years
building companies what really matters
is
the technology development that you make
which means how often you're iterating
and then you can measure that by how
much progress you're making between
those iteration Cycles that's basically
the game that we're playing a figure and
we played at Archer it feels like you're
like playing with connects or something
you know what I mean it felt like play
when I was at your office I remember
people were chilling I think I came on a
Friday and people were just sitting
around
um and I they weren't drinking beer or
anything but it was like that same like
Vibe of like we're just sitting around
like and they like giggled when like the
knee moved you know what I mean it felt
like you're like it was almost like a
glorified Lego set a little bit it felt
pretty exciting
yeah I think it feels like uh
I would say it probably feels like the
most Cutting Edge r d lab you could walk
into
with a focus to move fast and [__]
product
how big how big is figure going to be in
10 years
I think the space is it's the it's the
world's largest ham
it's I think it's probably most similar
to like autonomous vehicles in terms of
like the technology development the risk
to developing and deploying the
technology but I think it's easier to
scale we don't have the same safety
um hurdles that self-driving car would
have to have to drive safely and on on
you know on city streets and not Harmony
not harm anybody at those speeds and so
I think it's I think it's bigger than a
self-driving industry and I think it's
easier to scale it once it's working
um
so I think if we can demonstrate our
robots in commercial opportunities and
we're learning like we're we're in
commercial
um work doing useful work and we're like
training our neural Nets with real world
data and getting better recursively
getting better
I happen to think this this business is
probably valued bigger than cruise and
waymo which are like these are 30
billion pre-revenue companies
and I think we can do those over the
next like 24 months we'll have robots in
commercial
applications with like some of the
world's biggest brands
in five years you think figures in the
in the um
40 50 billion dollar
value range I just think like this is a
really big industry and we're we're
we're so five years from deploying
robots into commercial opportunities
that are making money it'll be in very
low volumes but you'll be able to see
the robots doing useful work and you'll
be able to see the robots getting better
over time
I have to think I'd be a really large
market cap who knows what what it'll
look like
um I think it'll be significant to where
even where we stand now and then
hopefully within 10 15 20 years we're
like we're seeing
we're seeing robots at scale and
Commercial opportunities really help
fill that void with the labor force that
we talked about earlier I wish I would
have invested more I think I invested 25
000 I should have done more yeah it's
it's risky stuff so I don't yeah it'd be
uh 25 000 makes me feel good I don't
want to lose too much of your money so
um I wish I would have done more but
dude I appreciate you doing this you
inspired me I think um
I think that like I'm you and I are not
the same and I appreciate that people
like you exist in the world you are
significantly Bolder than I am but I
hope that the takeaway for people
listening is like
that [__] wears off on you so like
whenever I hang out with you like I feel
I feel bad about myself in a really
great way like where I'm like you know
it's like when you hang out with like a
really fit athlete you're like oh man I
thought I was fit I'm nothing I could
totally step it up like I can push this
thing way harder I can I can I could go
way I could push myself way more than I
thought I could that's how that's how I
feel like when I'm around you you know
you are
you're a really special person and I'm
very thankful that I get to like hear
some of your wisdom I think that um
one of the things on this pod and in my
life we try to find people early and I
have a feeling that we are very early in
your journey and that you're going to be
a very very big deal a bigger deal than
you already are in the next five or ten
years and I'm very thankful that we're
able to like you know we bought your
stock early yeah thanks Sam that's the
Pod all right now show me the robot
[Music]